hello everybody I'm some rats aha I am a
customer engineering manager for Google
cloud and I'm big syllabus concen
Milwaukee Wisconsin
thank you taking the time to join me
today to understand our perspective on
how to deliver a flawless UX for back
five several Monday so now joining today
we were you're gonna cover a few things
for instance you're gonna go over you
know what is black tie of cyber monday
what is successfully what is UX CX you
know how you prepare for it how you
execute on it and a wrapper and we're
gonna go over what a few concepts today
and the goal is to give an idea as to
how complex an undertaking can be and
how partnerships can help you solve for
a business critical time period so let's
start off with design for failure all
things fail no matter how strong you
make it it is gonna fail it's how you
recover that makes all the difference
and this is something that people find a
lot you know coming from a you know an
organization that's known for reliable
services but that's precisely sort of
the mind shift or the paradigm shift
that you need to get used to things fail
and how you recover define how
successful you become so just to put
things in context black tries out
Mondays when I feel holidays right I
love Thanksgiving for retailers right
it's a really important time period for
instance in 2019 you know Black Friday
sauce sales it was over seven billion
dollars in digital sales it was up 14%
from 2018 and 2019 cyber monday had
greater than nine billion dollars in
sales there was a 19 percent jump from
previous year so to put things in
perspective right that's a substantial
amount of sales that's happening over
very compressed time frame right you're
literally going from Thanksgiving to the
Monday after and you seem that much
sales comes through during that time
period so BRC a-- you know Black Friday
Cyber Monday execution impact you know
when it goes well obviously you know
your sales go up
he goes up it's great for business what
happened to go sideways what happens
let's say you have an outage for an hour
all right what is the impact on the
brand what is the impact on the customer
relationship what is the 1% impact mean
these are really important business
questions that need to be answered right
and this is where cloud can help you X +
CX user experience customer experience
what is it well you know a lot of people
now have mobile phones right and a lot
of people are exposed to the greatest
the latest and greatest when it comes to
you know how applications work our
websites work you know that's seamless
experience so for instance if you're
shopping this up right and you decide to
go and add three items to your shopping
cart right what's that a smooth
experience then the brand make it jump
through hoops to do that action you know
how smooth does the overall transaction
right a good user experience enables
your users to achieve the tasks that
they won't achieve alright in customer
experiences sort of the overall umbrella
around it it's not just the app it's how
we communicate with your customer it is
how they can get help if needed so
that's the overall sort of relationship
if you UX is very sort of specific
alright and invariably having a great UX
can make the difference between making a
sale which is not making a sale so for
instance what does a 1 second delay mean
to your website right a one percenter
lake and you know around the 7%
production in conversions it can mean a
poor user experience for your users and
that will also mean a loss in business
you move to a competitor so UX + CX are
pretty critical in terms of maintaining
a relationship and making sure your
users actually enjoy using your thoughts
right and after all is all about the
user
so you XCX during black 5 with Black
Friday Cyber Monday you know the these
stakes go much higher
right so for instance if you're
delivering a great user experience when
it's not Black Friday Cyber Monday
that's great but can you give a similar
experience when this
much higher load on the system so for
instance let's say that a person will go
in and buy let's say a pair of shoes
right and that entire thing can be done
with minimal disruption and the user
loves now during Black Friday 7:00
Monday let's say there are thousands of
users trying to the same thing at the
same time can you deliver the same
experience that made your customer love
your brand during a high-stakes period
so that becomes really important stakes
go up the revenue potential so much
higher but so is the business impact
right if things go down you know how do
you recover right what happens when
let's say that you have users in the
East Coast and your users are in the
Midwest you know can you give similar
user experiences to both sets of users
because they wouldn't be right
it wouldn't be consistent experience in
the brand if somebody say in Milwaukee
has a three times higher load time than
somebody say in New York City all right
so these are consideration that become
really important but again it amplifies
so much more during Black Friday Cyber
Monday
you know to help you understand this to
help you figure out what is important
versus what it's not important I would
encourage you to think in terms of
critical user journeys right so what is
important to your user what is important
to your business right so for instance a
user for you know it might be really
important to buy say crayons right so
they can ship it to their knees in
Florida right now that could be super
important that music journey is really
important not for your business it might
mean that you want to have a feedback
survey filled out because you get
information you can better your service
right but to use it that may not be as
important but they are zones of
intersection between what's important to
you user most important to your business
and when you figure out where it
intersects it can help guide you in
terms of where do you need to put more
resources to harden those systems so for
instance checkout is super important to
your business and user because the user
wants to go buy stuff out shipped and
completed with minimal disruption for a
business it is extremely important too
because that's straight line to the
money right so you can figure out what
the intersection points are to help
guide you design your systems harden
your systems and provide the best user
experience for a business critical time
period
so why is it so hard I kind of alluded
to this previously right you know doing
back twenty-seven money you can see up
to 3x to 4x three times or four times a
traffic than you would normally and
there is no it may not be a steady
pattern it could be very spiky traffic
so you might see a whole bunch of users
you know hit your systems within the
first hour of your sale starting up all
right or it could be something like your
several spikes because your promotions
going out every other hour right so the
traffic is very spiking right and it is
substantially larger than what you
normally find outside of Black Friday
Cyber Monday
right so with that in mind you know how
do you how do you counter that
traditionally what you would do is you
accept compromises you would say you
know what Black Friday Cyber Monday
super critical to me all right in order
to meet that demand I'm going to over
provision my resources throughout the
year so now you pay for redundancy for
the rest of the year or you come to me
and say you know what I'm willing to
take the hit all right I'm going to
serve under provision knowing that it
has a slightly negative impact on my
customers right but that's a compromise
and that's why you know having your
resources in the cloud having a cloud
native sort of mentality towards
developing your solutions can really
help is are you resources elastic can
they grow and shrink with the usage are
they you know redundant across different
regions you know what happens when say a
region goes down right oh these are the
kind of things that you have to bring to
the table when you're trying to address
a very distributed user base right who
have high expectations on any user
experience because that's kind of what
you've grown to build with your users
you built a relationship that you want
to protect and notion right and with all
that comes in stuff like you know you
have a distributed system you know how
how do you how does the database handle
asset transactions right how do you
guarantee that consistency these are
certain things that start cropping up
which are not normally seen in
traditional monolithic application not
normally seen and fro ditional on friend
deployment right so these are things
that make it much harder and it usually
takes a completely different approach to
be successful in the club but the
payoffs are there the payoff
as well pay office again a great use
exquisite cannot stress enough what the
goal should be is provide the passengers
experience so that a user can enjoy
working the brand and building a
relationship up with you so what does it
look like you know kind of internally
right and this is fairly sort of
standard in terms of how people approach
you know how teams approach approaching
peek all right
you have capacity plants you've got to
figure out how much capacity gonna need
all right
you have load testing you have tabletop
exercise so this is stuff like you sit
down and figure out okay our database
has gone down what do you do then
alright let's say you decide you're
gonna simulate a network outage to the
east coast what do you do then how do
you fail oh right
then obviously you have black trial
Monday all right and sometimes it's
called depending the organization you
are sometimes you Institute code free
sometimes you don't right it depends on
you approach to how you develop products
right yeah Black Friday Cyber Monday and
then you know tapering towards December
you start scaling down all right so you
understand your capacity you scale up
you test deliver and scale down so all
this is a very very compressed time like
off very sort of a lot of activities
going on just to deliver on that short
timeframe oh it's a breaking down
first of all definition of success what
does success mean all right this is a
business critical objective like what
does it mean for business
in order to be successful once you have
that you can start figuring out what do
you need to do to deliver on that right
then you have core activities you know
load testing do you test - three times -
four times the amount of load that you
normally get all right tabletop
exercises which I just went through you
know do you simulate sort of different
failure scenarios right and you figure
out what are the lines of communication
you know how do you respond to outages
like disaster recovery testing boy this
is something Google's famous for all
right this is where you figure out you
know things again things are going down
how do you recover how quickly do we
cover where do you recover - you know
fellow let's say that you have regions
compute regions in east and west right
sake argument let's say East goes down
right
how did failover so that your users on
the East Coast are not significantly
impacted there is a degradation of
service that's for sure
right the latency went up but how do you
make sure that they still can use your
service and that's right rollback
strategies what happens when you decided
push an updated can you roll back
smoothly let's say that the update
caused a bug pebbles not caught until it
was in production sometimes these things
do happen can you actually roll back and
you know with confidence right
communication you know how do you
communicate your lives how do you
communicate outages right what is that
internal business process right and most
important who decides who's a decision
maker so let's say that we decide that
you're gonna fail over from central to
west all right let's take argument you
know who's going to pull that button
who's gonna push that button luck who
makes that final decision others chains
of communication as they've been clearly
demarcated and our teams and power to
make those business critical decisions
right so again fairly complex but for
really good reasons now do you have the
architecture deliver I think all right
is your application or your application
or the monolith with suggest a good
services micro services you know what
can a cloud design patent see using
right are these multi region systems are
these distribution systems how will
rotate disaster recovery right four
nines five nines reliability right
you've got to figure out who the error
budget is you've got to figure out you
know how much effort are you willing to
put in to give a certain kind of
reliability right because nothing's
gonna be a hundred percent reliable
you've gotta figure out your trade-off
right implicational e persistence Li the
implication that in compute right the
implication is scaling so again the
architecture that can help you deliver
for peak becomes really really important
so there's a sample architecture right
off you know let's say an e-commerce
fish application right and there's
certain things that are pretty common in
this kind of architecture but the key is
you know you start with the user you
have users disputed say
across the nation or globally right and
the fun little bodice you route a user
if you will to the resources that is
required to complete their user journey
that's closest to be use right in this
case what are you seeing as you have
region one on the Left you region two on
the right
right connecting those two is a cloud
load balancer on top so think of it as a
request coming in from the user hitting
the load balancer which decides should I
sing the users request to you know the
east or should I send the users request
to West Region wanna region - all right
within those regions you have compute
resources in this case we have gke
alright you have essentially that's you
know more from Microsoft's is kind of
approach right then you have a
persistence layer cloud sequel a
memcache or datastore whatever we are is
important to your business right
underlying all that even analytics layer
right so big query and the the the
architecture is a distributed
architecture
it's a highly available architecture
right if region goes down can you resume
services in this architecture you can
write is this repeatable what if you
decide to stand up a third region write
this architecture is marginally enough
that you can repeat what was successful
in both regions and stand of another
region this allows you to also test you
know pushing out updates so again it's a
very difficult architecture okay and
gives you the flexibility to scale up it
gives you the safety to withstand
regional outages right it also gives you
the the template if you will to expand
out as a business grows now this is a
fairly you know these are some of the
services that you would have in a
traditional set of e-commerce
applications right as you can see you
have a whole bunch of digital services
if you have searched economy you know a
whole bunch of services that are
required for a user to be successful
right and you have other services
non-digital you know shopping delivery
and stuff like that but again what I'm
trying to impress upon here is to
deliver a great ecommerce application
there are a whole bunch of services that
need to be built out right and there's a
lot of cloud
design pattern that you go to you know
implement to be successful all right
especially because again are you service
is elastic enough is your infrastructure
elastic enough resilient enough to
handle high loads all right and to allow
for disaster recovery to happening
things go badly and also scale down once
you execute it on peak so this is a
topic all by itself right I did want to
mention it right size reliability
engineering all right this is very user
impact driven right this is more about
you know for a infrastructure for
somebody who maintains say hard it will
take an example or somebody who is
developing an application right things
of interest might be you know what is
the CPU percentage you know a
utilization percentage right now those
are interesting things I and are
important pieces of information that
help you solve for problems right but
what is the impact on the user right if
you don't start approaching it from user
impact for instance let's say that you
want a user to be able to browse for the
products on your website right and you
want the search results to be returned
within say one second you know now if
that is impacted now that's a user level
impact right and that can help guide the
business better in terms of solving for
a better system that is providing search
results right now the underlying pause
right might be lets say CPU utilization
right maybe right but if you're not
guided by the impact on users right it
becomes very hard to figure out what is
important for users and most important
business right I would encourage you to
go into a sorry and a lot of resources
are on a blue cloud to help you
understand in where's sre fit in and how
do you do log develop and deliver
reliable systems at velocity so that
your developers your product teams can
make cool stuff right but they can also
deliver stuff reliable reliable and
maintain reliably as well common threads
success so in my time I do right I've
seen some teams be very successful in
delivering a great great about myself
right and some of the things that I've
noticed with that my teams as well as
noticed right that helps people be
successful you know there are clear
objectives communication right great
communication people know you know your
objectives are communica Munich eight a
clear right
the teams are empowered to make
decisions right and mistrust you know
the embrace cloud maiden thinking again
it's designed to scale the elasticity
that is important to deliver on those
experiences is really important then
power of partnerships leverage your
partners right they have helped solve
some of these problems for others right
but more importantly it is in their
interest to help you be successful so
it's sort of the all you know embracing
approach that is defined that is sort of
you know guided by overall objective
business objectives users object success
in DCP as you can see we have a you know
quite a few of our customers who have
partners Medusa to be successful and you
know hoping that we can help out you
achieve your business goals thank you